[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 13 janvier bienvenue dans
ce journal sur tv 78 et l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes voici
les titres de cette édition
il a officialisé sa décision en fin de
semaine dernière jean michel fourgous
sera bien candidat pour un nouveau
mandat et l'encours le maire et
président sortant de saint quentin en
yvelines mènera la liste allait
elancourt aux élections municipales et
de cinq candidatures à villepreux courau
ce goal gaulle avait la tête de liste de
tout simplement villepreux il avait un
temps envisagé de s'allier avec le maire
sortant stéphane mirambeau avant de
prendre ses distances
enfin le projet de carrière dans le
vexin menacé le cimentier calcia vient
de perdre le soutien du conseil
départemental des yvelines son président
pierre bédier a envoyé samedi un
ultimatum au groupe implanté à guerville
qui prévoit de transférer son siège dans
les hauts-de-seine première partie de ce
journal donc dédié aux élections
municipales deux invités à suivre dans
cette édition est d'abord jean michel
fourgous bonsoir bonsoir mr les
républicains d'elancourt président de
saint quentin en yvelines vous serez
candidat donc pour un nouveau mandat
dans la ville où vous êtes élu depuis
1996 vous mènerez la liste alliés
l'encours cette décision de vous
représenter ce qu'elle était évident
pour vous ça nécessitait tout de même un
peu de réflexion de votre part nous
c'est une liste d'union très élargie
très rassemblée sur la base des
compétences et genre plus de 50% de la
liste de revient du secteur associatif
et après vous avez l'ensemble des
grandes du grand courant elle est rude
et quelques j'en ai l'air est menée en a
quatre et puis un peu de centre gauche
jean weiss et c'est vraiment une liste
de compétences et je rappelle souvent
que les idéologies diviser les
compétences rassembler aujourd'hui une
équipe municipale plus que jamais je
trouve je vois dans les sondages on 15%
questions des français sentent que les
clivages gauche droite sont dépassés
c'est bien que tous les maires toutes
les listes montre bien qu'elle
accompagne ce phénomène
donc pas de clivage même si vous êtes
toujours adhérent à aux républicains il
y aura lui leur sensibilité politique
dans ça durera 4 ou 5 e presque donc
c'est tendance mais chacun mais sa carte
avec un renouvellement il y avait tout
le monde est alors un renouvellement
vous et 50% tous les six ans vous avez
quasiment sur l'ensemble des listes de
précédentes de renouvellement donc un
grand projet bien sûr
et l'on courait à la chance d'avoir
d'abord en termes d'emploi si on regarde
les attentes de nos administrés l'emploi
bien sûr l'emploi c'est une niveau
économique que vous avez bon vous avez
un bassin d'emploi quand même très très
riche et l'encours saint quentin paris
saclay ces six et demi de chômage c'est
des emplois plutôt de très haute valeur
ajoutée c'est c1 je crois un emploi pour
ces emplois pour un actif dont est quand
même assez un modèle économique
les très belles boîtes sur des secteurs
d'avenir que l'on accompagne d'ailleurs
avec bien sûr 50 individus assure
ensuite vous avez le deuxième c'est
l'éducation l'éducation et l'emploi est
devenu un modèle scolaire en france
la preuve l'école de formation de
l'éducation nationale viennent se mettre
à l encours avec l'objectif d'être
formés 4000 profs parents dans cette
avec la nouvelle pédagogie donc
française aujourd'hui qu'on est entré
dans la pédagogie du numérique voilà est
également les douze communes se sont mis
sur ce même modèle et l'éducation
ascione d'ailleurs vient le 5 février je
crois faire son plus gros colloque
national au vélodrome dont vous êtes
tous les âges et tous les inspecteurs du
gaz en salle qu'il travaille sur cette
nouvelle pédagogie d'envoyer en iran mon
coeur de la réforme de l'éducation
nationale de la modernisation là donc ça
c'est pour l'éducation avec un objectif
élevé un objectif sur nous on se fonde
que sur dix ans si on prend un enfant au
primaire au secondaire et qu'il arrive
au supérieur avec en plus l'université
paris saclay qui va devenir la première
université française lui qui va intégrer
pleinement cette université à l'horizon
2025 qui s'allume en venir c'est de
saint quentin qui va intégrer
paris c'était donc en fait on on
travaille sur un parcours de réussite
scolaire
du primaire jusqu'à cette université qui
sera bienvenu la spré scientifique très
technique très numérique d'ailleurs et
bien entendu les enfants qui ont la
chance de rentrer dans ce processus aura
un avantage on vise même l'augmentation
de la performance scolaire environs de
près 30% domcile bien sûr suivre tout le
cursus avec cette nouvelle pédagogie
on a même une classe d' autisme parce
qu'en fait tous ses moyens aujourd'hui
permet d'intégrer donc on est une des
rares communes de france
à voir
une classe six spéciales pour l'autisme
oui c'est ça permet une ouverture
fantastique donc je vous dis économie
enfin emploi éducation a pressé la
sécurité sécurité c'est une
problématique qui intéresse davantage
les habitants
aujourd'hui les nos habitants nous il
encore toi sont très sensibles aux
problèmes de sécurité et l'iman font pas
régulièrement et donc nous on a monté de
trois policiers a reçu municipaux à 32
aujourd'hui quand même en puissant armée
aujourd'hui à une brigade canine une
brigade équestre vous avez un centre de
vidéo comme de plus de 100 caméras et
surtout vous avez ce fameux commissariat
du futur donc d'agglomération qui arrive
à elancourt grâce au giro dont il faut
quand même le dire et bien entendu qui
va avoir les meilleures technologies les
meilleurs moyens bien sûr pour assurer
les meilleures conditions de sécurité
d'une part pour bien s'occuper des
victimes pour bien protéger si nos
policiers et puis pour que la justice et
la police donc soit encore plus rapides
plus fiables voilà donc des conditions
de sécurité qui vont augmenter mais
attention il faut quand même trois ans
pour le construire
ensuite vous avez un projet sportif de
haut niveau avec ces fameux jeux
olympiques une fois dans la carrière
dans une vue ville vous voyez les jeux
olympiques donc les emportements la
chance de ils vont voir ça ça va être
une aventure extrême ça va permettre de
développer un esprit sportif bien auprès
des jeunes en termes d'intégration les
valeurs de l'entreprise entrepreneurs
elles sont assez proches des valeurs de
ce sport c'est les forces et c'est une
sorte d'autonomie une force
psychologique vous trouvez en soi même
japon et donc on va beaucoup travailler
là-dessus le rebond la colline de la
course avec l'occasion ses 40 ans que
tout le monde se dispute sur un projet
avait coûté ça va être à peu près à
l'occasion mais tout le monde d'accord
avec lille de loisirs il ya un projet
commun entre eux
sur cette cette fameuse colline des
locaux et il y le loisir et ça permet de
faire des pistes cyclables ce qui est un
plan vélo comme il ya trois sites vélo
sur les quatre lots nous le golfe les
trois sites vélos vont être rassemblés
autour de lisier loisirs ils vont
permettre vraiment une transformation de
cette île de loisirs avec dans le cadre
des jeux olympiques d'avoir des moyens
qu'on n'aurait jamais eu donc plusieurs
priorités pour ce nouveau mandat sur
lequel voilà vous vous êtes candidat
merci jean michel fourgous d'être venu
en plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire sortant d'elancourt président
également de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et vous êtes la tête de liste allez
elancourt aux élections municipales en
face de vous pour le moment une seule
liste déclaré une liste de gauche
réinventons elancourt qui est menée par
catherine perron fin raufast avant
d'accueillir mon deuxième invité autres
informations en lien avec les
municipales leur en somme le
rassemblement national investi un
candidat aux mureaux nicolas brède sont
29 ans conduira la liste du parti
d'extrême droite dans la ville du nord
des yvelines ses priorités l' équilibre
fiscal la proximité avec les habitants
et la sécurité à nicolas brep son
quatrième candidat en lice aux mureaux
où sont en course également le maire
sortant divers gauche françois garay
agnès étendard et la tête de liste sans
étiquette est d'agir aux mureaux enfin
hervé riou mène la liste divers droite
elle mureaux pour tous à villepreux
commune de près de onze mille habitants
il y aura au moins cinq candidats pour
ces élections municipales dont le
premier tour est je le rappelle le 15
mars prochain parmi eux kouros golgoht
lab
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez 50 3 ans
vous êtes médecin de profession et vous
conduirez la liste tout simplement
villepreux au scrutin je précise que
vous êtes le président du mouvement
citoyen notre ville près de la
copropriété et des eaux du moulin
pourquoi vous engagez cette fois ci dans
une démarche politique
écoutez je suis comme vous avez dit le
président d'une copropriété à villepreux
donc je rencontrais des difficultés sur
ma copropriété qu'il s'agisse que
l'entretien des des espaces faire
des des installations publiques donc à
chaque fois les gens me considérait
comme un référent comme un maire local
il se retourner vers moi et alors qu en
fait en tant que président la
copropriété j'avais pas beaucoup de
pouvoir
au niveau local donc j'ai été confronté
à l institution publique à la mairie à
saint quentin pour les faire intervenir
et ma démarche était que j'ai dû
corriger les différents un problème de
ma copropriété et j'ai dit au moment des
élections politiques municipales je vais
aller voir les différents candidats et
soumettre les problèmes qui se posent la
circulation la densification de
l'urbanisation les problèmes des espaces
faire la sécurité est un mec question se
sont rajoutés les questions de toute la
ville progressivement est jeune et qu'on
sa portée par les candidats n'a pas été
satisfaisant contre je me suis retrouvé
face à des candidats qui étaient
particulièrement limoux rejeter arrogant
j'ai été insulté j'étais menacé de
procédure alors que j'étais pas candidat
aux élections et ils m'ont invité à
faire une liste
et c'était assez dur pour moi qui aie
qui est 30 ans ou 35 ans de carrière
professionnelle derrière moi j'avais
déjà été traité comme ça et vous avez un
temps envisagé de vous allier au maire
sortant stéphane mirambeau avant d'y
renoncer
l'élu qui a été assez critique sur
l'exacte internet à votre égard il peut
moi je pense qu'il est un petit peu amer
après notre séparation les questions que
j'ai subi là que j'ai soumise la seule
personne qui a accepté de répondre
malgré la dureté des questions que je
lui ai posé sur son mandat sur son
comportement c'était la seule personne
qui a accepté de me répondent sans
arrogance sans menaces et sans insultes
mais pourquoi ça ne s'est pas fait au
final cette union alors l'union dont kim
habitudes de vie rejoint - tu me rejoins
et on va faire j'ai dit pourquoi pas
donc il fallait une cohérence dans ma
démarche et on n'a pas pu se mettre
d'accord parce que tout ce que je lui
proposais sur la culture sur l'urbanisme
finalement il n'était pas trop d'accord
il était un petit peu dans un esprit de
revanche qui étaient toutes à totalement
compréhension du fait qu' il ya une
implosion de sa majorité dans deux
listes différentes qui s'entraîne
d'ailleurs pas ensemble un contexte
tendu aussi on rappelle qu'une plante
est toujours en cours d'instruction pour
harcèlement sexuel - c'est la nuit en
m'ouvrant de tous âges et même pas
facebook je te sastre mes patients ou
les personnes que je croise ou pas avec
qui je dois travailler
j'estime dans un premier temps qu'ils
sont bons sûrs et ils doivent faire
preuve de leurs qualités
donc je voulais pas entrer là dedans on
a été salie quand on salit quelqu'un ans
elle aussi sa ville et les gens les
plaignants ils se retrouvent sur les
deux listes
et
municipales sont aujourd'hui mais mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais mais
rivaux donc je voulais pas entrer dans
ces considérations j'ai dit ça il faudra
que tu vois de ton côté
si jamais il y à une procédure est mise
en examen il faudra qu aux lentilles à
la conséquence manque on a préféré et
retrouver chacun sa liberté et à ce
moment là il a été un maire et donc vous
avez ville et les reproches ou les
insultes qui ont été moins lourde envers
moi sur un terreau discus ça veut dire
si vous avez envisagé de vous allier
stéphanie en beau que d'une certaine
manière vous êtes satisfait de ce qu'il
a pu mener les projets qu'il a pu mener
à la tête de la ville depuis 2008
quel regard vous portez là aujourd'hui
je m'efforçais de son jour le problème
c'est que je travaillais 12 jours avec
lui
les autres listes ont frappé 12 ans avec
lui et je m'explique toujours sur ce
projet d'alliance le j'abandonnais mon
projet passe derrière le bilan de
stéphane rambaud sur le plan financier
était positif je vous rappelle que il a
été il est est rééligible à 60% d'élus
et avec ses affaires la majorité a
exposé jeu donc
par contre il a laissé tomber beaucoup
de choses dans la vie il s'est axée
principalement sur l'urbanisme avec une
densification à je dirais à outrance la
culture il a complètement abandonné la
sécurité au manque de policiers on a du
mal à recruter l'éducation notre collège
n'aura pas assez de place et il a ils
ont tout le monde même les listes qui
sont jour deux concurrentes
ils ont accepté ils ont voté le 17
décembre la vente d'une partie du
terrain du collège pour construire
encore des immeubles ce que je ne valide
pas mes projets notamment celui du
central park c'était le quartier on le
met en suspens depuis longtemps et qu'il
a si j'ai l'honneur d'être élue équipe
qu'on me fait confiance on la met en
suspens et on va revisiter le programme
pour voir notre mille mètres carrés même
vivement
alors il ya même une question d'une
nappe phréatique en dessous qu'on a
essayé de passer sous silence on sait
pas si c'est de la pratique est valable
existantes ou pas et franchement la
ville est content on ne peut pas
absorber on va on va passer de 10000
habitants à quatorze mille habitants à
aux alentours de 2025 nous ça c'est un
projet que vous le souhaitez mettre de
côté juste pour préciser les choses vous
êtes adhérent les républicains est ce
que cette liste la liste que vous portez
va porter cette couleur justement où
tout il y aura de diverses sensibilités
the party les républicains qu'ils vont
apprendre que je suis candidat ils sont
même pas au courant je pense que
l'histoire le problème de la ville
qu'il s'agisse des espaces faire des
poubelles la sécurité c'est pas une
histoire d'hommes étaient république là
et notre ville je tiendrai investiture
vous revendiquez pas d'investiture
rendement jeu non il ya une candidate et
on ne peut pas dire que les républicains
il est génération de terrain je crois on
change de la peine deux mois après moi
personnellement j'ai aucun soutien
politique sur le parking d'un traité
affronte qui a un adhérent mais sur ma
liste
il ya des gens de tous bords politiques
moi je suis pas un politicien je suis un
habitant de villepreux de plus 20 ans je
veux améliorer ma ville réanimer la
culture redonner une santé de proximité
un centre de santé de garde il ya le
genre de vol est de proposer une
nouvelle offre de santé sas a fait écho
aussi à votre profession de médecin
c'est quelque chose d'important c'est
très important parce qu'aujourd'hui de
quelqu'un qui a vibré ou aux
clayes-sous-bois quand il a un accident
quand il ya une urgence il faut qu'ils
se déplacent à poissy bouche et nez avec
les urgences saturé on peut on a les
possibilités mais il faut avoir les
réseaux il faut avoir la connaissance il
faut avoir l'âge pour aller discuter
avec le médecin et les toubibs rôle ou
prennent en considération de développer
un centre de garde qui serait qui sera
ouvert de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à
minuit avec un minimum par exemple une
radiologie au sud et pulmonaires et
qu'on fasse le tri et le traitement des
gens sur place
c'est un service aux personnes âgées et
aux personnes en situation de handicap
aux enfants c'est primordial
donc d'autres projets vous les avez
évoqué juste pour terminer villepreux
est une commune bien sûr intégré dans
cette agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis 2016 avec forcément des
projets à mener au niveau intercommunal
la commune qui est bien représenté
stephen mirambeau et vice président de
l'agglomération sylvie ce vin montel à
une délégation à l'école innovantes quel
regard vous portez sur le travail mené
au sein de l'agglomération est ce qu'il
est suffisant est-ce qu'il faut
l'améliorer
et l'horizon ils ont globalement ils ont
pas fait du mauvais travail je conçois
la précédente missive est très bien
travaillé ce que je regrette c'est que
lille pour eux ils ont laissé partir les
commerces
on n'a pas soutenu contrairement par
exemple aux clés on a une petite
subvention de l'agglomération 700000
euros contre 7 millions de presque 7
millions d'euros pour les caisses du
bois avec à peu près la même population
on a très peu de marge de manoeuvre
alors ça aussi c'est un élément que la
municipalité n'a pas su défendre pendant
huit derrière du commerce de proximité
inscrits alors leurs taxes leur
contribution compter pour cette
subvention que ne touche plus
aujourd'hui si on n'a pas de marge de
manoeuvre
ils ont fait des éléments positifs mais
ils ont oublié beaucoup de choses et je
répète la culture un théâtre et qui
coûte entre 40 à 70 milles euros
aussi subventionné par l'agglomération
mais qui est fermé portes fermées donc
fournir son début de campagne pour
terminer alors nous avons quatre dates
le 25 janvier le l'état tout comme au
début février
et puis fin février et début mars
alors les dates exactes je peux vous les
donner et 25 janvier samedi 25 janvier
simple 18 février samedi 22 février et
dimanche 1er mars
merci coureuses golgoht la tête de liste
de tout simplement villepreux à ce
scrutin des municipales face à vous la
candidature du maire sortant stéphane
mirambeau celle de l'ex adjointe sylvie
sauvain montel valérie ben porter une
candidature citoyenne enfin là le
délégué départemental du modem jean
baptiste à monique sera également tête
de liste
et pour clôturer cette page municipal
cette annonce grégory gary astier sera
candidat pour un deuxième mandat
maurepas le maire sortant divers droite
l'annoncé aujourd'hui dans un courrier
transmis aux habitants l'élu sera a dit
il à la tête d'une équipe renouvelée au
delà des étiquettes politiques parmi ses
priorités poursuivre la construction du
centre aquatique reconstruire la halle
du marché détruite par un incendie
encore créer une mutuelle communal une
le notre liste est en course pour le
moment à maurepas menée par le
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
gauche
ismail havane et grégory gary astier qui
a présenté ses voeux aux morts pas bien
c'était vendredi au programme du
discours bilan de 2019 est mise en avant
de quelques habitants une médaille a été
remise aux pompiers engagés lors de l'
incendie qui a touché la halle du marché
en juillet dernier pour l'occasion la
municipalité a créé la médaille d'or de
la ville les propos sont recueillis par
mélanie poker c'était quand même plus de
30 pompiers qui se sont mobilisés avec
la grande échelle qui avait servi
d'ailleurs à éteindre le feu de notre
dame
plusieurs casernes réunis
et donc c'était pour moi aussi
l'occasion j'allais dire avec les
pouvoirs qui sont les miens de leur
offrir tout notre reconnaissance par la
médaille d'or de la ville qui n'avait
jamais été frappé donc nous l'avons fait
pour eux c'était au moins le minimum
qu'on leur devait avoir un le bretonneux
la mer alexandra rosetti fait une
tournée des quartiers pour présenter ses
voeux jeudi soir c'était à la maison du
maire en tête dans le quartier du centre
village l'élu est revenu sur les projets
des dernières années et des futures
comme la construction de l'écoquartier
de la remise ou la création d'une maison
pluriprofessionnelle de santé à la mère
de voisins-le-bretonneux a également
fait part de son inquiétude liée à la
perte d'habitants mille quitté la
commune en 15 ans manon varaldo pour
l'interview
cette baisse d'habitants elle finit par
être préoccupante pour la ville puisque
les écoles se vident et donc on va
perdre en attractivité en dynamisme on a
des services qu'on veut préserver donc
les nouveaux logements qui vont être
construits sur voisins-le-bretonneux
clermont permettre peut-être de remonter
un petit peu le nombre d'habitants et
puis d'accueillir de jeunes familles
afin de répondre à nos propres besoins
et mais aussi aux besoins des salariés
de saint quentin en yvelines qui peinent
parfois à trouver à se loger
et pourtant c'est un besoin très
important pour préserver nos entreprises
sur le territoire
je pense qu'il faut absolument arriver à
développer les transports en commun qui
viennent de la vallée de chevreuse
aujourd'hui en a pas qui passe en tout
cas par nos par nos communes le reste de
l'actualité locale avec cette réunion de
crise ce week-end pour le département
des yvelines la collectivité annonce
rentrer dans l'opposition face à calcia
l'entreprise avait obtenu cet été
l'autorisation d'exploiter une carrière
dans le vexin
c'était avant d'annoncer sa volonté de
transférer son siège des yvelines vers
les hauts-de-seine ce qui a déclenché la
colère du président des yvelines
mathilde et demi pour les précisions
colère et trahisons pour pierre bédier
président du département des yvelines
il dénonce l'attitude de l'entreprise
calcia qui a annoncé la délocalisation
de son siège social dans les
hauts-de-seine sans en avertir le
département
nous avons été trahis par cette société
et par des patrons
voyou qui au mépris de la parole donnée
au mépris des engagements pris et au
mépris des salariés de l'entreprise
organise un départ en catimini du
territoire sur lequel il ne laisserait
que les activités polluantes et tout ça
pour mener un plan social qui ne dit pas
son nom puisque à l'instant où je vous
parle on fait pression sur les salariés
pour les amener à démissionner puisque
on les déménage à plus de 30 km la
société calcia l'intention d'exploiter
une nouvelle carrière dans le vexin et
organise son départ vers rueil malmaison
un événement qui vient fragiliser
l'emploi local et qui attise
l'indignation des élus
en ce qui me concerne la confiance est
tout à fait rompu donc même si on a des
promesses avant le jeudi après midi
moi je rentre maintenant résolument dans
l'opposition à calcia parce que ses
promesses même si elle arrive avant
jeudi
elles ne peuvent être que de papier ce
sont des promesses qui engage une
construction industrielle lourde qui
engagent des engagements sur la carrière
lourde et je pense que même si les
prennent pour deux ans pour trois ans
dont 3 en or a le même problème
la confiance est donc rompue pierre
bédier a annoncé qu'il demanderait jeudi
16 janvier une révision du plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal pour interdire
l exploitation de la nouvelle carrière à
bruille en vexin
une opération coup de poing menée par
les marcheurs cueilleurs ce dimanche
l'association environnementale à
ramasser des déchets au bord de la
nationale 10 au niveau des essarts le
roi
l'objectif alerté les autorités
sensibiliser les automobilistes nicolas
d'andry et patrick jacques de dixmude
ils se considèrent comme des lanceurs
d'alerté pour cette opération l'alertent
aux déchets est donné au bord de la
nationale 10 aux essarts-le-roi une
quarantaine de marcheurs cueilleurs ont
rempli 122 sacs poubelle soit près d'une
tonne de déchets sur environ 500 mètres
de voie c'est une mission une des plus
difficiles en effet peut-être une bonne
vingtaine et aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment le summum
on a ramassé plus de 60 bouteilles du
rin
qui émane des routiers qui balança par
les portières ou qui balança lorsqu'ils
sortent des camions cette association
créée en novembre 2018 veut nettoyer les
espaces naturels et sensibiliser à la
protection de l'environnement
cela dès le plus jeune âge j'aimerais
ville vivre dans une ville propre y
ramasser tous les déchets parce qu'on
n'est pas bon pour la planète
cette partie de la nationale 10 une zone
déjà traité par les marcheurs cueilleurs
malgré plusieurs courriers à la
direction des routes d'ile-de-france la
situation n'a pas évolué c'est un point
qui est connu pour être très sale pour
pas vous dire plus
et pour rester correct et rien n'a été
fait en un an c'est à dire cap
personne n'est jamais venu nettoyer
personnes s'en occuper il ya ni
prévention ni sensibilisation éviter
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui il faut
sensibiliser à outrance
il faut que tout le monde s'y met il
faut que ça soit les élus faut que ça
soit exemple les associations faut que
ça soit dans les écoles faucon
réapprendre le civisme faudra apprendre
à plus jeter à moins consommer vous
voilà c'est c'est tellement vaste toutes
les semaines les marcheurs cueilleurs
yvelinois sont sur le territoire à la
chasse aux déchets dans les yvelines
mais aussi dans toute la france
aujourd'hui l'association est déployée
dans 26 départements dans quelques
instants le retrouve aux commandes du
cetud sport mais d'abord sa
traditionnelle chronique pour le un
éventail des résultats du week-end dans
le département de l'ariège bon sens
nikkei d'action tv 78 on commence tout
de suite cette rubrique résultats par du
basket le championnat de nationale 3 un
derby yvelinois retour des vacances
samedi 11 janvier marly le roi rose se
mettra pour le compte de la 12e journée
sur la première période trappe favori de
la rencontre dominée creuser car
rapidement face au dernier du classement
le score à la pause 44 à 30 mais la
vérité d'une première période n'est pas
forcément celle d'un match marly-le-roi
0 victoire depuis le début de la saison
grappy peu à peu son retard sur les
visiteurs mais le réveil des mara lee
choix et trop tardif les trappistes
remporte la victoire sur le score de 67
à 70 secondes allait elle est pour moi
catastrophique on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait on n'a pas défendu
on a pas on n'a pas respecté notre
équipe on n'a pas respecté l'adversaire
parce qu'on n'a pas joué à notre niveau
de jeu la deuxième période a été un peu
mieux parce qu'on a mis un peu de rythme
au début parce qu'on a défendu un petit
peu ce qu'on faisait pas sur la première
place et qu'on a posé quelques
difficultés sur nos rotations défensives
même si des fois on s'est laissé avoir
et qu'on a trouvé de la lascivité
surtout c'est ce qui nous a aidées et ce
qui nous a permis de revenir au
classement marly le roi est toujours
dernier avec zéro victoire en 12 matches
de son côté trappe remonte à la 4e place
à seulement un point de la 2e place la
prochaine journée est programmée ce
samedi à 18 janvier par l'unrwa ira à
fécampoise et trappes se rendra à vous
du football également ce week end
versailles se ressaisit après sa défaite
en 32e de finale de coupe de france les
versailles se sont imposés 3 buts à 0
face à l'équipe 2 du paris saint germain
lors de la 13e journée du championnat de
nationale 3 au classement les joueurs de
la cité royale conserve la tête avec
quatre points d'avancé sur leur dauphin
ivry prochain match le 25 janvier sur le
terrain de créteil lusitanos un dernier
résultat on termine par du rugby michael
le championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir a
perdu un match important dans la course
au maintien les hommes de sébastien
roncalli se sont inclinés contre les
derniers du classement lors e à
l'extérieur score final 22 à 11 cette
défaite est synonyme de surplace au
classement les plaisirs voir revenir
l'avant-dernier orléans et n'ont plus
que trois points d'avancé sur le dernier
prochain match dimanche prochain contre
à marcquois merci michael pour ce point
sur les résultats sportifs du week-end
avant de refermer ce journal cette
information qui ravira forcément les
amateurs de rap avec ce clip tourné dans
les yvelines soprano et niño était dans
le quartier de la sourde oreille à
montigny le bretonneux vendredi soir
tournage du clip de música extrait de
phoenix aux étoiles réédition du
cinquième album de soprano à l'artiste
originaire de marseille qui s'est prêté
au jeu des selphy avec les fans présents
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]